COMMUNITY.
THIS INTERVIEW WAS FULL OF
THINGS OF SUBSTANCE THAT
ACTUALLY AFFECT YOUR LIFE.
I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT
THE OTHER END OF THE SPECTRUM,
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
ALLIED TOTAL FOCUS ON SCANDAL
AND OBSTRUCTION.
DEMOCRATS TOOK THE HOUSE LAST
YEAR PROMISING ACTION ON REAL
ISSUE.
THAT IS GONE.
NOW THEY ARE PROMISING ON
ENDING INVESTIGATION AND
OBSTRUCTION.
THEY ARE FACING CHEERLEADERS
IN THE MEDIA, LOVE IT.
>> NEW AREAS FOR INVESTIGATORS
TO LOOK AT TRUMP'S TAX
RETURN.
>> YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS
WINDING DOWN.
WE ARE JUST GETTING STARTED.
>> MICHAEL CULLEN'S TESTIMONY
IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE FIRST SERIOUS
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS
OF DONALD TRUMP.
>> CHUCK TODD, LAURA AND ALL
THE REST OF THEM, THEY HAVE
DISAPPEARED RIGHT UP THEIR OWN
BACKSIDE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
SUBSTANCE OR POLICY.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE'S REAL
LIFE.
THEY ARE THE DEFINITION OF
DECADENCE.
ISOLATED IN THEIR
ESTABLISHMENT BUBBLE, ZERO
EMPATHY FOR THE STRUGGLES OF
WORKING AMERICANS, ADDICTED TO